I want to tell you about micro Finance
because you might want to either donate
to it or get some money from it I
especially want to tell you about gine
America which is a micro Finance bank
that I support the most micr Finance is
small loans to people who don't have any
money for them to build businesses
they're typically a few ,000 in size for
small Endeavors like buying a rug
cleaning machine to get into the rug
cleaning business the banks I financed
are in economically depressed areas so
it's been incredibly satisfying for me
to see people in these undeserved
communities flourish and in some cases
evolve into pretty big businesses with
that type of financial support for every
dollar I donate roughly $12 is loaned
out and paid back over the next 10 years
so the money keeps going round and
around to help many people over many
years for that reason I love donating to
gine America and micro Finance if you're
philanthropic and you want to have an
impact on underserved communities you
should consider it or if you are in an
underserved community and are looking
for a grub steak that will give you the
opportunity to start your small business
check it out